IS TO FLATLINE.
AND THOSE ARE MY THOUGHTS AT THE
END OF DAY 30, AMERICA AND
SHUTDOWN.
JOINING ME NOW A SMALL BUSINESS
OWNER, ONE WHO ATTENDED THE
PROTEST AGAINST MICHIGAN’S
STAY-AT-HOME ORDER TODAY.
THE VOLUNTEER WITH THE MICHIGAN
CONSERVATIVE COALITION.
MATT, YOUR GOVERNOR ESSENTIALLY
SAID TODAY THAT YOU’D BE STUCK
IN THE HOUSE ANYWAY BECAUSE
THERE’S SNOW ON THE GROUND.
A SNOWSTORM IN MICHIGAN.
YOUR RESPONSE TO THAT.
>> IT’S JUST RIDICULOUS.
I MEAN, ULTIMATELY HOWEVER -- IS
SO FED UP WITH BEING SEQUESTERED
AND TREATED LIKE SMALL CHILDREN
IN THAT WE CAN’T SOCIAL DISTANCE
AND BE DILIGENT ABOUT PERSONAL
HYGIENE, FOLLOW CDC GUIDELINES
AND STATE PRACTICES AND, YOU
KNOW, WE WANT TO TAKE OUR LIVES
BACK.
ONE THING THAT WE LEARNED
THROUGH THIS IS THAT THIS IS
GOING TO BE THE NEW NORMAL.
COVID-19 IS GOING TO BE IN OUR
LIVES FOR AT LEAST THE NEXT YEAR
UNTIL THERE’S A VACCINE AND WE
NEED TO FIGURE OUT A WAY TO GET
BACK TO AS NORMAL OF A LIFE AS
POSSIBLE WHILE THIS PLAYS OUT IN
THE BACKGROUND.
THE SOLUTION IS NOT TO LOCK US
INTO OUR HOMES.
>> Laura: I’LL SAY IF YOU SAY
WHEN WE GET A VACCINE, IT ALWAYS
AMAZES ME TO HEAR PEOPLE SAY
WHEN WE GET A VACCINE.
WE DON’T HAVE AN HIV VACCINE.
WE DIDN’T COMPLETE A SARS
VACCINE.
SO THE IDEA THAT THERE’S
DEFINITELY GOING TO BE A
VACCINE, THAT’S AN INCREDIBLY
INVOLVED PROCESS, NECESSARILY
SO.
AND IT MAY OR MAY NOT HAPPEN,
BUT MEANWHILE, GOVERNOR WHITMER
IS SAYING THAT WHAT YOU DID AND
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE THERE, IT
WAS JUST A POLITICAL STUNT.
CHECK IT OUT.
>> IT WASN’T REALLY ABOUT THE
STAY-AT-HOME ORDER AT ALL, IT
WAS ESSENTIALLY A POLITICAL
RALLY, A POLITICAL STATEMENT.
IN THE FACE OF ALL OF THE
SCIENCE, ALL OF THEM -- THE
STAY-AT-HOME ORDER THAT WAS
ISSUED.
A SMALL GROUP OF PEOPLE THAT
CAME TOGETHER WITHOUT MASKS ON,
BRANDISHING THEIR WEAPONS,
HAVING POSTERS OF BEING
ANTICHOICE.
THIS WAS A POLITICAL RALLY.
>> Laura: SHE SAYS IT’S
POLITICAL AND SUDDENLY SHE
STARTS BRINGING UP ANTI- -- I
MEAN, I DON’T UNDERSTAND THAT
BUT IS THERE ANY FAIRNESS TO THE
CRITICISM THAT IT WASN’T A
BIPARTISAN GROUP OF PEOPLE, IT
WAS BASICALLY JUST A BUNCH OF
REPUBLICANS WANTING TO MAKE HER
LOOK BAD?
>> IN FACT WE WENT OUT OF OUR
WAY TO MAKE THIS BIPARTISAN.
THIS IS NOT A POLITICAL ISSUE.
TO US, WE WOULD HAVE COME OUT
AND HAD THE SAME PROTESTS WITH A
REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR OR AN
INDEPENDENT GOVERNOR, WE JUST
THINK THAT OUR CIVIL LIBERTIES
ARE BEING VIOLATED AND DECIDED
THAT THE ONLY WAY THAT WE COULD
HAVE OUR VOICES BE HEARD WAS TO
ENGAGE IN BASIC CIVIL
DISOBEDIENCE AND, YOU KNOW, WE
HAD A LOT OF UNITY.
THERE WERE OVER 10,000 VEHICLES.
OVER 600 TRUCKS FROM THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY, INCLUDING
CEMENT COLLARS.
WE HAD PEOPLE FROM THE
LANDSCAPING INDUSTRY, HEATING
AND COOLING, BOATS BEING TOWED.
SO IT WAS --
>> Laura: WITH GOT TO GO.
WE ARE SEEING SIGNS OF LIFE IN
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC BECAUSE
THERE ARE A LOT OF US WHO ARE
OUT THERE SAYING -- LOOK, AND
THE STATES, ESPECIALLY THE ONES
THAT HAD VERY RELATIVELY FEW
INFECTIONS COMPARED TO WHAT WAS
BEING PROJECTED, PEOPLE ARE
DYING OUT THERE.
SMALL BUSINESSES ARE DYING,
PEOPLE ARE MISSING SURGERIES.
PEOPLE HAVING TO TAKE PAY CUTS
IN THE FIELD OF MEDICINE BECAUSE
ALL NONESSENTIAL SURGERIES ARE
BEING PUT OFF.
THERE’S A LOT OF PAIN OUT THERE
THAT HAS BEEN OVERLOOKED AND I